the One Piece manga just dropped a ton
of shocking new information about some
of the most mysterious characters in the
entire story in fact we now know that
the leader of the incredibly hyped up
Knights of gods has to be somehow
related to Shanks but that's not even
the craziest name reveal of this chapter
because after Decades of mystery we now
finally know the full names and jobs of
every single member of the gorosei but
if you thought that that was it for this
chapter you're completely wrong because
we also learned emu's ancient family
name plus the true nature of this island
destroying weapon that might have the
power to destroy the entire world and
with all of the secrets of the world
government being revealed right now they
are clearly being set up as the single
most powerful group of enemies in the
entire story amongst others that is
because in this chapter we meet this
older looking gentleman with possibly
the most epic hairstyle in one piece
which is saying something who is called
garlic figure lens and we're being told
that he is the leader of the Knights of
gods who protect marijuana and now we do
know that he is undoubtedly going to be
an absolute Powerhouse of a fighter even
at his admittedly Advanced age and that
is because he has the same family name
as Shanks at least that is extremely
likely because the gurose speculated
that utta would be a figure land too if
she was shanks's daughter and I guess
the only way they could come to that
conclusion would be if Shanks was a
figure lens and if you didn't know in
one piece power usually is inherited
pretty well from generation to
generation so just like Luffy is super
powerful in Parts because of his
ridiculously overpowered grandfather and
father shanks's power must have
partially come down through his family
lineage which should mean that Garling
should also be an absolute monster of a
fighter in fact back in chapter 1082
buggy even revealed that Shanks always
Shone so brightly with potential even
from a very young age so him coming from
a super strong family just makes even
more sense and if you have any doubts
that Shanks and Garling are absolutely
related then listen to this because this
chapter also very casually dropped one
of the most unexpected reveals that I
can remember for a long time because
Garling himself is actually the previous
king of God Valley and in case you've
forgotten God Valley was an island where
Goldie Roger and GARP teamed up to take
down the legendary rocks Pirates which
included big mom kaido and Whitebeard
and of course rocks himself we do know
that the celestial dragons used to live
on this island however after this battle
the island was completely wiped off the
map and while Roger rescued little baby
Shanks from that Island which by the way
basically confirms I think that Garling
is shanks's Dad or grandpa or something
since they were both from that Island in
both figure lands I personally never
really expected to meet someone from God
Valley so it was a complete shock to see
the former King who must surely know
many of the secrets of what took place
on that day including the true reason
that Rock's attack got well in the first
place and what actually happens to the
notorious pirate but all of that will
surely be revealed in the future and
this brings up a few burning questions
though like what are garling's powers
and who are the rest of these incredible
Protectors of marijua really I only see
see two options for the rest of the
Knights of God here the first is that
Garling here could just be their leader
and the rest of them are all other super
strong Fighters not necessarily related
to the figure land family it could even
be that they are the strongest Celestial
dragons from the other original 20
ruling families I will say though to me
personally the other and much more
interesting possibility is that the
Knights of gods are entirely made up of
this figure and family and you might be
asking well why is this the more
interesting option well that's simply
because if Garling is shanks's father
grandfather Uncle I mean some other
distant relative then we could see his
mother siblings or other relatives in
the story as well and if that's the case
then surely we have to see Shanks
interact with these people at some point
as well I mean why else could they be
introduced into the story so late and
I'm not sure if this would necessarily
mean a fight if Shanks actually comes to
marijua or maybe Shanks actually gets a
along with his long-lost family and we
could see them interact in a more
meaningful way there is also the theory
of course that shangs is actually still
a member of the Knights of God and that
theory is kind of supported by this
famous scene here with Shanks apparently
speaking with the gurusai back in
chapter 907. however I don't really
believe this Theory especially because
of the possibility that this figure
could just actually be shanks's brother
or even a twin and honestly generally is
it just me or has Oda just been
delivering one 11 out of 10 chapter
after the next recently like everything
we're going to discuss in this video is
gonna be absolute top level material
which is why it also deserves an
absolute top level sponsor which is
holtzkern who's speaking of top level
material have been the single most
unique sponsor on this channel that I'm
honestly really excited to work with a
second time here now holtzkirin is an
austria-based company close to where I'm
from that produces these incredible
looking watches and accessories made
from natural materials like wood Stone
and metal that will make you feel like a
powerful pirate Captain yourself like I
guarantee you that Blackberry would
absolutely try to get his hands on a
ring like this or this incredible
looking watch that just makes me feel
extra confident whenever I wear it when
I go out but the reason I really
appreciate them so much as a sponsor is
because Healthcare really cares a lot
about a healthy earth and its resources
like right from the start they have been
cooperating with Charities to make the
world a little bit better just like
Luffy and right now until June 16th each
person who uses my coach donate O'Hara
and the link in the description below
will not only get a 10 discount but
haltkron will also donate five percent
of your purchase value split equally
between three Charities supporting
reforestation and Senegal animal
shelters for Street talks in Bucharest
and humanitarian aid for children in
Bangladesh so not only will you look
stylish like these one piece characters
here but also make a good impact which
of course brings me back to this insane
chapter besides wondering who they are
there is actually even more that we can
analyze about the Knights of God from
this mind-blowing chapter and it all
starts in the original Japanese because
the most literal translation for this
group is the Knights of God and with
this translation I strongly suspect that
these Knights don't actually serve the
entire group of celestial dragons but
instead only serve emu and maybe the
five Elders the one that's because
Sugarland here is actually addressed as
a saint himself but it is even more
supported by the reveal of the guru says
names which we will be discussing in
just a moment but if they really do only
serve the top leaders then I wonder if
they're actually from the void Century
as well I mean it's not likely but maybe
the reason that the world government was
so desperate to retrieve the opeopenomi
was because they wanted to preserve all
of their strongest Fighters and not just
emu I mean who knows there could be
another magical way to keep people alive
but regardless we all also have a clue
that they directly serve emu back in
chapter 908 because when we first see
emo revealed in their Garden you may
have ignored the fact like me that there
is actually some kind of servant in the
background as well and while I've always
wondered who would have the right and
even know about emu it would make sense
if that person was actually one of the
god knights in fact we even see this
large sword that emo uses to cut up the
pictures but emu doesn't take the sword
with them so it is kind of possible that
this sword belonged to the servant which
would be further support to the idea
that this is in fact one of the Holy
nights and so with this direct chain of
command it makes even more sense that
someone like Garling has authority to
deal out Justice even to the celestial
dragons themselves which is exactly what
happened in this chapter because we see
this guy myosguard having been executed
because office support for the straw hat
grandfleet members who be beat up the
Celestial Dragon in the last chapter
also because he probably beat him up
himself but on top of that we actually
also know that meals guard helped PSY
and Leo get away because back in chapter
1054 Akainu kizaru and this other
high-ranking Marine are actually talking
about the event we just saw in the last
chapter and so because of this he has
apparently been executed on the
authority of the Knights of God and
while we don't 100 know that they were
the actual ones who ordered the
execution were at least told in chapter
1054 that they have complete authority
over anyone in the Holy Land although
I'll say I'm dying to know what kinds of
Power these holy nights actually have I
mean is it some mysterious power like we
just saw with the gurose and emo in the
last chapter or will it be something a
little bit more quote unquote normal
like crazy devil fruits and hockey well
no matter what the powers of the Knights
of God will turn out to be they are
basically spring chickens compared to
the insanely destructive powers of this
weapon right here and while we already
know what this device's powers can
actually do in this chapter we learned
that this legendary machine is in fact
not an ancient weapon not the weapon
Uranus as many including me probably
suspected but instead it seems to be
some sort of technology created by the
genius scientist Dr vegapan and you
cannot imagine just how much this would
change the direction of the story
because if this thing is really
technology that can be recreated then
that means that the world government
might be able to make more of those
weapons to wildly increase their
potential for Destruction across the
world and while I don't think that Oda
will go full rumbling in the one piece
World here we have seen super powerful
Tech be recreated and used in the story
before after all when we first saw the
cyborg Posse fista on Saba ODI we could
not imagine that these super powerful
awful robots would become an entire Army
like they have been at Marine forts well
actually hold on let's let's back up and
add a little bit more context here
because even though this was made by DR
vegapunk this device could still be
related to Uranus in some way or form
because remember way back in Enos Lobby
Frankie had the blueprints to a weapon
that was supposed to be able to counter
the ancient weapon pluton so what if we
have a sort of similar situation here
what vegapung somehow made a device that
is similar or even a counter to Uranus
and that is what we're actually
witnessing destroying La Lucia which is
actually even crazier to think about
because it seems like the destruction of
Lulu Lucia was just a test run to see if
the weapon actually works because after
everything that happened during the
revelry it seems that the world
government decided that they needed to
move forward with their great cleansing
plans and decided to test out this
weapon and after it was apparently
successful in destroying this entire
Island they probably probably thought
that they will now no longer actually
meet vegapunk and could have him
assassinated which is actually
incredibly sad when you think about it
because I wonder if vegapunk originally
made this weapon for something other
than destruction just how Dragon seems
to be wandering in this chapter as well
I mean we have seen in many of the
recent cover pages that vegapunk was
pretty much a pacifist but many of his
Creations now get used for war and
Military purposes because they have
fallen into the wrong hands again even
in this chapter we do see the Dragon and
also ivankov are shocked that emo would
have created a weapon with the potential
for such massive destruction honestly
kind of interesting to think about what
would have happened if vegapunk had
never even joined the world government
in the first place might have been the
better choice and actually there is one
more detail about vegapunk and his
connection to this weapon that you might
have missed and that's because back in
chapter 1065 the Lilith version of
vegapunk mentioned that it would be
great if they had a powerful Alternative
Energy so source and she specifically
mentioned the phrase
eternal flame that was actually a ton of
speculation about what this could be
back when this chapter was released but
now in this chapter we learned that this
destructive weapon is called the mother
flame a very intriguing connection which
makes me think that vegapunk possibly
designed this thing to gather energy and
then it was somehow corrupted into a
weapon of mass destruction but all of
this talk about the ancient weapons
makes me wonder if the original 20 Kings
actually used the ancient weapons during
the void Century to defeat the Ancient
Kingdom after all someone must have had
used them at some point before so that
everyone knows what they're actually
capable of including destroying entire
islands and even the world itself and if
these weapons were indeed used to
overthrow Joy boy it would actually be
kind of fitting that in the present day
they might be used by Luffy and his
allies to combat whatever super weapons
the world government now possesses plus
speaking of crazy super weapons we
finally get to see the seraphim versions
of the other original Warlords
specifically crocodile Moria and
doflamingo who just has crazy I mean all
of them have swag but doflamingo here
fantastic which brings up another Super
interesting question that I've actually
been wondering about ever since the
seraphim were introduced specifically
for crocodile and that is what's
vegapunk actually able to recreate logia
devil fruits using the green blood
technology because so far all of the
other Sera theme have only had paramecia
type devil fruits so it will be
incredibly interesting to see if he was
able to give ascrog the sandlogi powers
and I mean if he was able to reproduce
them then wow I mean is it possible that
we will be seeing even more ridiculously
powerful logia fruit users in the near
future I mean I wonder if it could even
lead to a Genetically Enhanced type of
soldier with insane logia devil fruit
Powers nothing's impossible at this
point but wow I mean this is a lot to
think about and all of it has me super
excited for what we're about to see in
the final battles of the story but now
more than ever we seem to know that the
gurosei will actually take part in those
battles and in this chapter we don't
learn any more about their powers but we
do get their full names titles and roles
as leader of the world government so
let's go through each one of them and
see what types of Secrets we can learn
here and first of all each of the
godosei has the title of warrior gods
senshinokami in Japanese and this
actually further supports the idea that
they are Fighters but also is
interesting in another way because
they're specifically called godsier and
as we all know they are not the first
self-proclaimed God that we have seen in
the one piece world of course the
lightning fruit user animal calls
himself a god of skypier before he was
then defeated by the straw hats the
celestial dragons basically consider
themselves Gods the lunarians were once
considered a tribe of gods plus the
d-clan is known as the natural enemy of
the god so clear really the DS will be
opposing these Warrior gods in the near
future and in fact now that you mention
it the way that these five are titled
kind of reminds me of uh these guys here
all of these have specific roles under
NL and were all defeated by various
straw hats and of course this guy so is
this a hint that the gorosei might fall
in a similar way later on in the story
anyways let's start with Saint Ethan
Baron van nasuduro who is the warrior
God of Finance now there are a few
details here that we can actually pull
from this name and his title first my
original idea from chapter 1073 the
review I did back then was that each of
the godosei were related to planets in
the solar system and this turned out to
be basically true I mean although we
have to play with the names a little bit
here to make it work for Ethan Baron we
can basically make Venus by combining
the V and the nasu to make vinasu it is
his first name I think that is
especially interesting here that's
because the Judo portion of nasojiro
bears a strong similar polarity to some
names that we do know from wano for
example Zoro was called zorojiro by many
of the Wana citizens so it is actually
possible that this man is originally
from wano plus he wields what many
suspect is the shodai kitetsu which is
one of the most famous cursed blades
from wano but enough about his name we
also learned that his responsibility is
related to finance however one thing
that is kind of unclear about each of
the gorose's role so far is whether this
responsibility extends to the entire
world and all of the kingdoms part of
the world government or if their roles
only deal with marijua and honestly it
is probably a mix between the two
depending on the godosei because in this
case I could see that Saint Ethan Baron
could be in charge of the Heavenly
tribute which World Government kingdoms
are required to pay now next up is Saint
Marcus Mars who is the warrior god of
the environment and I'll be honest I
really don't have a great idea for what
this guy's role in the world government
is supposed to be I mean environment is
basically as vague As It Gets a term and
unless he's somehow in charge of the
weather and can alter the weather all
around the world or maybe they really do
worry that too much technology will be
bad for the environment I mean who knows
maybe they have climate change in one
piece another possibility is that he
could be the one in charge of this giant
bridge that you probably all forgot
about but I'm really not 100 sure about
this one however his first name is Mars
so there's an easy one for the planets
here interestingly Marcus is an ancient
Roman name including one of the most
famous Empress Marcus Aurelius also
interestingly Aurelius was known as one
of the five good Emperors and the last
emperor of the Pax Romana which was an
age of peace and stability for the Roman
Empire which does seem kind of similar
to the era of One Piece although it
hasn't been entirely peaceful let's put
it that way maybe and then we have Mr
mustache himself Saint Topman Valkyrie
whatever name who is the warrior gods of
legal Affairs and there's a few things
that stick out to me right away first
off Valkyrie is a clear reference to the
Nordic Valkyrie who were mythological
female warriors who usually guided the
dead souls to Valhalla now my initial
thought was could this mean that he
might be from elbaf since that is a
country based on Nordic mythology and it
is a little bit harder to connect his
name to a planet but I have seen someone
successfully combine the man and Curie
to make something like Mercury so we'll
count this one as well now in terms of
his role in the government's legal
Affairs remind me a lot of the judicial
island of Anna's Lobby and the prison in
pull down so perhaps it was his job to
oversee these important government
facilities so maybe he's the one to ask
if the one piece is actually at the
bottom of the hole underneath Anna's
Lobby and he would probably also be the
one who's the most unpleased about the
straw hat since they busted both imple
down and Anna's Lobby and moving on
we're now going to Saint Shepherd Jew
Peter
guy who is the warrior God of
Agriculture and this blonde fellow is
clearly tied to the planet Jupiter now
as far as other secrets from his name it
could have been inspired by Saint Peter
who was one of Jesus's first disciples
in the Christian Bible so perhaps this
means he was also one of emu's first
followers when they took power over the
world governments in Catholicism they
also believe that Saint Peter guards the
Pearly Gates which is basically the
gates that someone must pass through to
go into heaven we do have the gates of
justice so might make sense they are
connecting kind of all of these
locations that we talked about in this
Lobby and pull down and of course Marine
Forge or at least what's left of
marineford and Saint Shepard's role in
the government is agriculture honestly
this one is also a bit of a head
scratcher for me I mean clearly it does
seem to deal with food in some way or
form but farms and other agriculture are
not super common in the one piece world
so I'm kind of wondering if he's just in
charge of food on the ritual or if again
it's kind of encapsulating the entire
world and you might have actually
forgotten that we have seen Island
specifically related to food before in
fact in chapter 827 we see a few of big
mom's children stealing flower eggs and
fruit from islands that are designed
specifically for these fruits so maybe
Saint Shepherd is the one who is in
charge of these types of islands only on
a world scale but then again some people
consider fishing a part of Agriculture
too and there is certainly a lot of fish
in the one piece world so it might just
be that and then we have Saint J Garcia
Saturn and while we already knew his
name we now also know that he is the
warrior God of scientific defense which
actually perfectly explains why he's
coming to eckhead Island since his role
in the government basically to oversee
the technology that is mostly developed
by vegapunk but now that we do know all
of their names we can add these to the
list of the nine original ruling
families that we currently know about
these family names are the nifatari Jay
Garcia Marcus Hoffman Shepard Ethan
Baron donkey shot figure lands and
narona which if you read this chapter
you will know that there was actually a
saint Emu from the narona family among
the first original ruling family so here
they seem to be your secret ruler of the
world narona emu which is kind of crazy
that we went five years basically
knowing nothing and now in three
chapters we have a ton of insane
information about them but let's explore
all of the secrets that we can speculate
based on what was revealed in this
chapter first off because there was a
saint emo we have to wonder if this emo
in the present story is actually the
same one from the void Century or if
they are a descendant of the original
Saint emu who somehow took power over
the world and I mean who knows there
could even be some other interesting
body swapping Shenanigans going on here
since that was another key power that
doflamingo highlighted from the ope
opinomi and now that we have their
family name I'm super curious if you
could eventually see someone else with
that name as well in the story I mean
certainly if emo is a descendant of the
original ruler there would have been
another member of the family
specifically emu's parents for instance
but we'll have to wait and see if such a
person actually exists and what role
they could possibly play in the story
however that's of course not even the
most interesting thing here though
because the actual name nerona May
reveal some more secrets about emu
itself on its own now we already
mentioned Saint Marcus's possible
connections to ancient Rome but did you
know that Nero is another Infamous Roman
Emperor and pretty much unlike emu
Nero's rule was incredibly chaotic as he
was known for his cruelty and selfish
behaviors however interestingly Nero was
born only a few years after Jesus from
the Bible was killed which is an odd
coincidence with emu and the world
government taking over the world by
defeating joyboy who was possibly called
the sun Gods beyond that Nero was
eventually betrayed by the Roman senate
and after his death Rowan had a brief
period of Civil War which might actually
fit pretty well with one piece
considering we're technically about to
enter a civil war between the world
government and the Revolutionary Army
but enough history because there is at
least one character in the story who
thinks that emo is Immortal and that is
the Revolutionary ivankov who speculates
in this chapter that emo received the
Perpetual youth surgery from a former
user of the ope opinomi which honestly
is not surprising I mean we've all been
speculating about this possibility for
years but it is interesting honestly
seeing it brought up as an option for
the first time in the story as well but
then you know what's coming since Oda is
actually bringing it up right now I do
wonder if this is not just another red
herring to kind of get us away from the
actual source of Emo's abilities and all
of these secrets are about to spark an
unbelievable era of Chaos in the one
piece world because we Leaf of this
chapter with big news Morgans hinting
that he's about to send out his loyal
flock of news Clues with information
that will shake the world and it's
pretty easy to Guess that he's going to
Spill the Beans about emu but maybe it
will also include some other secrets
about the world government emu or even
the poster boy of the Revolutionary Army
himself Sabo because more than ever it
seems like Sabo will be playing a much
larger role in the story than anyone
could have ever imagined when he was
first reintroduced into the story as an
adult way back in chapter 98. wait hold
on chapter 98 yeah that's right I bet
you didn't know that Sabo was probably
shown in the manga right here all the
way back in loketown and if you want to
hear more about that and 100 other
incredible secret facts about One Piece
you probably didn't know then you can
watch that video right here thanks for
watching don't forget to check out
holtzkern in their insane products and
I'll see you in the next one